foreign
I was being paralyzed by debt so
um in desperation found Dave Ramsey's
method and systematically over the past
12 years have
turned it completely around
so my question is now
that my wife and I have done that we
have two small children we're kind of uh
very very frugal with our money we saved
about 90 percent give or take a month of
what we earn
and uh now we have a different problem
is
learning to live a little bit
um
you're still living out of a trauma
response brother
yeah I I think it's uh you know just
fear obviously there's a lot of guilt
success guilt and I know this is
um I was a success story with this and
so now we're in this
different stage of
um the recovery and it's great and it's
a good problem to have
but uh that you know as other people
experience this and and you know it's
just it's kind of this unknown for me is
how to
give a little yeah did you um
we could probably get sidetracked here
so I'll I'll keep my question pretty
direct did you have a pretty chaotic
childhood
um no I think uh we had uh you know my
my parents were in debt uh a lot we had
a you know motorcycles we did my dad
kept us active all the time and so you
know we
it was just kind of we we did certainly
didn't live within our means
um and uh so that that obviously was
learned by me and then uh you know then
I got into medical school and I got
tremendous amount of debt and it was
really every day I was waking up with
mounting debt and the interest climbing
and so it was in 2011 I just had that
massive realization that you know I I
need to change something I need to have
have goals are you a physician Nick
yeah all right so my academic research
my nerd work was
simply put I studied people who other
people in the community go to for help
and care
okay I studied the mental health of
attorneys and medical personnel and
pastors folks that other people go to
and what I would tell you is yeah you
had a big debt issue
but my guess is you have a broader issue
because what and you know this
pathologically speaking and I want to
not get too nerdy for our audience here
but
if you've got a body responding to Trump
if you've got a body that is living in
an anxious ecosystem the moment you
knock off anxiety one your brain just
moves on to anxiety too into three
so your body was telling you
probably we owe a lot of money we
haven't slept in a long time I'm
suddenly being in charge of keeping
people alive or well I'm trying to
navigate a family I'm trying to navigate
a crazy uh political ecosystem all those
things happening all at the same time
and so the alarm system that spins up
your body it's almost like throwing
darts and it says it's the money and
then you live like a maniac because
you're Nick and you can and you'll pay
this thing off
and without addressing that core
anxiety almost almost ocpd you get
underneath all that and then your body
just moves on to the next one so now the
problem is you've left your community
behind you've become one of them Nick
and then you you don't have to have joy
in your life and then once you start
having fun it's just going to move on to
the next until you deal with that uh
that lower level
identity shift which is we weren't safe
we are now
and that is a different conversation
than can you give us a three-step plan
to go have more fun do you see what I'm
saying this is about creating a
non-anxious home for Nick and his wife
and his kids
and that will make you better you're on
point there uh everything you said just
it's it's very true
so so what I've seen professionally and
um just walking alongside people is the
further upriver you can get to create
here's the fun exercise you and your
wife go out for a half day retreat
and you all get to do something that
probably never happened in either of
your homes which is you'll get to plan
and dream about the future
you'll cross this Finish Line you
survived you paid off all your debt you
got everything right sized in your home
and now y'all are playing pickleball for
the first time you've never played this
game you don't know the rules and so
you'll have to practice you all got to
figure this thing out and so
what kind of home what do we want it to
feel like when when you walk home honey
here's what I want to feel like when I
walk in the front door how can we create
this home that is warm or that is funny
or that is joyful and we're going to
reverse engineer that and begin to come
up with this home this non-anxious life
she might look at you like my wife did
me and say I want you to stop working so
much
or I want you to love us as least as
much as your clients or patients or the
folks that you are coaching and that was
hard for me and I asked her like here's
what I need and here's what I want and
we address that stuff and dude I'm
telling you the anxiety alarms they
melted along the way
and having joy and having fun and
creating a date night and making okay
we're gonna have to spend x amount of
dollars because ninety percent is
mathematically insane so let's back it
down to 70 and we are going to practice
spending this 20 we're going to go on a
date and we're gonna buy a real nice
meal and we're gonna feel uncomfortable
about it and we're both gonna call it
out with a smile on her face I feel
uncomfortable I feel uncomfortable I
feel guilty I feel guilty and maybe we
tip the waitress a hundred bucks on a
hundred dollar meal just because we can
but we're going to begin to feel that
and own it and metabolize it so that we
can transition to this new identity
which is a couple that's not running for
our lives and a couple that's not
anxious all the time but we are a couple
who is living peacefully into the future
how does that sound
man that is awesome it's uh my dream so
well I really appreciate your time now
you got it yeah I mean
here's the magic words go out on a
retreat and create a new identity for
Nick's home who are we honey who do we
want to be who do we get to be now
the second thing is I want you to be
highly intentional about setting a
certain aside a certain amount of money
a month to give away
and I want you to see that gift I want
you to see the eyes light up when you
give that money away don't just write
checks and and send them via email and
the third thing is I want you to set
aside some money that y'all gonna
practice spending on yourselves and hang
on the line I want to get your address
I've got a new book coming out in
October called building a non-anxious
life and I'm going to send you the first
copy that I get I'm going to mail it to
you as my gift when it comes in
um dude you got exciting things ahead of
you man I'm proud of the work you're
doing to change your family tree my
brother we'll be right back